hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of people are talking about ever
since it was played yesterday uh in the
grand finale of the spain's got talent
uh it's ray enigma versus uh former
world chess champion anatoly karpov uh
and um uh to my understanding as the
whole thing is in spanish and i've seen
ray enigma on twitter and on other
social media for the past like maybe a
year and a half uh the thing is no one
knows who he is uh so he's been going
around everywhere playing chess you know
taking photos with people and uh well he
he's just a very interesting individual
and we don't know who he or she uh
you know is and i know you guys are
probably thinking oh it's probably young
misha he came to exact his revenge on
karpov but no misha is still very young
and
i don't think it's max deutsch i know a
lot of you guys are thinking it's max
deutsch but i don't think it is uh
because if you check out his twitter
everything is in spanish so that could
be you know sort of a tricked to
fool everyone but uh yeah you know until
proven otherwise i'm going uh with he's
definitely spanish and uh well as he is
incredibly strong in chess he's
obviously uh
one of the spanish grand masters but you
know it could really be anyone now i
don't i don't think it's been revealed
who he is as i haven't found any
information on that on the internet but
even if you guys know don't share in the
comments you know let it remain a
mystery so um to my understanding again
as uh the the video is in spanish i will
put a link to it you can check it out
even before watching the analysis
because it's just you know uh very very
very powerful stuff uh you know it's
three minute blitz game uh and you know
everything is just flying off the board
so in order to understand the game a
little bit better maybe you should also
check out the video uh but i don't think
ray here knew that he was going to face
karpov in the finals of this spain's got
talent edition because when um a a a a
different individual sat across uh him
over the board and then he just stood up
and then you know uh
lights started flashing fire started you
know
going all all around the end
and italy carpo just uh walked through
the door and you know uh enigma was a
very
well he seemed very surprised that he
was going to face karpov over the board
now uh but if you guys have any more
insight on this do share in the comments
i i will uh you know like and uh and pin
it for for everyone else to see now
let's check out the game and uh for
those of you who have already seen the
video uh enjoy and enjoy the analysis
because uh well you might think it's uh
you know some sort of a weird game where
nothing is happening but it's actually a
very very correct game so let's check it
out uh enigma with the white pieces
opens with d4
uh we have knight to f6 knight to f3 and
now e6 we have e3 so going for the uh
you soup of rubinstein system of the
indian game and now usually players just
go b6 bishop to b7 and continue playing
as the bishop will be very well placed
on this diagonal but karpov uh as he is
very sneaky plays bishop to e7 he's
checking if ray really knows his stuff
we have bishop to d3 and now only now b6
we have knight b to d2 and uh carp of
strikes in the center with c5 we have c3
defending the center and now bishop to
be seven placing the bishop on this long
diagonal queen to e2 and here karpov
trades uh once in the center we have c
captures e captures uh and now both
players castle so castles castles and
the d6 now by carpool we have rook to e1
uh interestingly this has all been
played before so you can uh be sure that
rey enigma is a very very strong
player we have a6 and now a4 stopping b5
uh knight beat to d7 uh and now there
are some games where knight f1 was
played also knights the g5 is a known
move but here uh ray plays h3 and it is
now as a move 12 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
karpov needs this he plays rook to e8 uh
and okay we have knight to c4 now
putting pressure
on some pawns here and the queen to c7
karpov just develops the queen connects
the rooks uh and now bishop to g5 white
also continues development we have h6
bishop to h4 and now knight to d5 karpov
offers a trade of bishops uh as he he
plays the bishop on e7 for a very good
reason it would seem uh bishop captures
on e7 knight captures and now knight
f2d2
uh asking uh carp what do you what do
you do here so here carpool goes knight
to d5 and excellent square for the
knight very centralized and here we have
queen to g4 so already trying to put
some pressure on the position maybe some
queen to e4 to h7 ideas are possible uh
but not very likely as the knight can
easily
just return to f6 and here an aggressive
player might just you know barge in with
it with e5 but not karpov he just plays
knight seven to f6 improves his position
a little bit queen to h4 as the queen
was attacked and only now when all of
karpov's pieces are nicely placed okay
you could maybe bring the rook into the
game before that but uh karpov strikes
on the queen side with b5 we have a
captures eight captures and now
the problem is uh your knight is
attacked and white decides to capture
the rook here now i will again remind
everyone this is a three minute blitz
game so three minutes plus zero seconds
increment so you can't really think all
that much uh but the the absolute best
move for white here is knight to the a3
but it's uh
not uh maybe all that all that great
because karpov can play knight captures
on c3b captures queen captures you grab
some pawns and you're gonna win back
your piece so it's uh you know for
example bishop captures you attacked the
rook and now well it's just a completely
crazy position but it is okay for white
however white played rook captures on a8
we have rook capture 78 and now it's
still the same idea knight to e3 or
knight is hanging here you have to move
it knight to e3 only the problem is
karpov doesn't capture on c3 uh he
instead goes for rook to a2 and okay
it's a three minute blitz game you don't
want to
overcalculate and then you know realize
that it leads to nothing so he just
improves his position and now he has a
well-placed knights his bishop is
incredible here his rook is putting
pressure on white's position so this is
uh a real karpovian chess we have knight
to d1 defending the pawn and now bishop
to c6 defending his b5 pawn uh we have
knight to e4 offering a trait of knights
and here karp of trades captures
captures now the queen
is trying to get to that h7 square so
just knight f6 attacks the queen and
opens up this bishop's diagonal so queen
back to e2 the queen now also defends
the pawn so maybe the knight can be
activated queen to b7 putting pressure
on the g2 pawn and now knight to e3
luckily now the queen defends the pawn
and the knight defends the g2 pawn and
now
again as all of karpov's pieces are
nicely placed he uh executes another
strike on the queen side with b for
trying to weaken white's setup here and
of course you can't really allow
captures here because you will not be
able to recapture so here is c4 uh we
have queen to b6 as carpal created a
weakness now karpov attacks the weakness
we have bishop to b1 first forcing the
rook to move rook back to a8 and now
rook to d1 defending the pawn and the
carp of pushes b3 interestingly this is
already moved 30 this is a three plus
zero blitz game and the game is still
completely equal if you put this into
any engine it will give you a zero zero
zero but of course uh that
is of
a little interest when you have like a
minute on the clock so here we have d5
uh uh striking in the center we have e
capture c captures attacking the bishop
here and bishop to b5 now the queen is
attacked queen to f3 uh defending the
pawn and also trying to get the knight
to f5 if the knight gets the f5 it's
going to attack a lot of important
squares here of course carpel knows this
and he plays bishop back to d7 he
doesn't want to allow knight to f5 so
here knight to g4 and now karp of trades
bishop captures on g4 h captures and now
another weakness has been created so
karpov attacks that queen to b4 just
attacking that pawn
bishop to f5 defending it and now rook
to e8 and now some maybe rook to e1
ideas may be possible so king to h2 and
now
we have rook to e5 again
tactically g6 works perfectly fine here
you can just kick away the bishop and
win a pawn even if bishop captures and
g6 threatening queen captures on f6 you
can play knight captures and g4 with
check first and after the king moves
only then capture and you will still
have a better position but karpov
doesn't like opening up his king like
that so he just improves the position
with rook to e5 puts more pressure on
this pawn here and now asks what do you
do we rook to d3 going after the b3 pawn
and now queen to c5 so karpov will give
up this pawn but it doesn't look like he
got all that much in return rook
captures on b3 and now you don't want to
allow rook to b8 the bishop is covering
h7 so he has to go back rook to e8 and
now we have rook to c3 attacking the
queen queen d4 and now b3 so now you can
move the rook the b two pawn will not be
hanging and well now white is up upon
and it's a past b pawn and those can be
incredibly dangerous so here knight
captures on d5 uh grabbing the pawn back
and now rook the d3 attacking the queen
so queen e5 check we have queen to g3
and now karpov has to decide what to do
there are plenty moves you can play here
for example knight to f6 you can play g6
when sixteen play king to f8 so uh all
of those are fine moves but knights the
f4 the move carp of played is not a good
move because it loses on the spot
however uh again i have to uh point out
that this is a three plus so blitz game
and players are incredibly low on the
clock seconds are on the clock and uh
ray misses his chance of rook to e3 it
just wins the game on the spot you can't
move the queen because captures rook and
the bishop covers h7 this is checkmate
and of course if you move it here to
defend the rook well then we just
straight captures captures and you pick
up the knight and this game over white
is up a piece that's it however uh in
the uh this terrible time skirmish rook
the f3 was played and no it was not a
mouse slip this was played over the
board uh now karpov just goes back
knight to e6 and the opportunity is no
longer present so here queen captures an
e5 d captures now rook to e3 going after
the pawn now knight d4
putting pressure on the bishop and on
the pawn the rook now defends the e5
pawn and now again if you throw this
into any engine it will give you a zero
zero zero but still you have to now play
an equal end game against anatoly karpov
which is not a walk in the park so rook
to d3 uh rook to b8 putting pressure on
the pawn here uh rook to e3 now uh white
also wants to pick up the e5 pawn and
carpool defends it with f6 we have
bishop to e4 uh now hoping for carp to
blunder because if you capture now with
real capture some b3 just bishop d5
check and you lose the game so carpo of
course plays king to f8 uh not only does
he
evades check but he also starts bringing
his king into the game which is a very
important segment of the end game so
bishop to d5 now defending his spawn and
now king is seven so it's a
pretty equal end game uh the thing is
this is a past pawn but uh with karpov's
king being closer to the passport than
white's king it's more of a weakness
than a strength so here bishop c4 king
to d6 we have rook to d3 and now king to
c5 we have g3
and now rook to a8 now trying to
infiltrate the position we have rook
king to g2 and now rook to a1 uh we have
rook to d2 and now king to b4 so getting
deeper and deeper into the position with
the king and now again it's a very
difficult position especially with the
seconds on the clock uh here bishop the
g8 was played but uh you know it's sort
of a trick trying to trick karpov into
into doing something that would be bad
for him uh but it's also just a
completely winning position now for
karpov so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this incredible
winning idea for carpool while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not capturing the
pawn because if you capture the pawn you
just give white all the counter play he
goes after the king side pawns and
that's it you will not be winning this
game and if you try to save the pawn
just check and then the knight falls and
then you're already lost so here king
the c3 is the move congratulations to
everyone who founded this you are uh you
know an excellent uh uh player of end
games and here uh the rook is trapped
the rook has nowhere to go covered by
the rook covered by the knight knight
and king king and rook and that's just
it those are all the squares that the
rook can use so here uh capturing maybe
on e5 can be played but uh instead
enigma played rook to e2 and now carpool
just captured that rook uh we have king
to f3 knight back to d4
king to e4 and now rook to a2 now you're
probably wondering why is enigma
continuing this game he's down the rook
well uh well there's also time the time
factor if karpov's clock runs out then
enigma wins the game so he's trying to
flag karpov here we have f3
rook to f2 now we have f4
rook to f3 so maybe even some check
painting czech mating ideas are are
possible here but it's not um
at all clear how is karpov supposed to
do this so here we have f5 uh and now
rook captures on g3 we have king to d5
he's trying to run away and keep the
game going rook captures on g for bishop
to h7 and now rook to f4 uh we have
bishop to g6 now just knight captures on
f5 so as long as karpov wins all of the
pieces and pawns and white is left only
with a king he can no longer lose the
game even if his time runs out it's
still only a draw so here king c6 knight
to d4 check we have king to d7 and now
e4 carpool now also starts pushing his
pass pawn bishop to h5 white is ready to
give up the bishop for the pass pawn e3
bishop to d1 and now e2 now the bishop
has to be given captures captures and
now b4 uh king captures on b4 and now
king to e7 so here carpool is of course
completely winning but he still has to
deliver checkmate otherwise he might uh
well he can't lose in time but the game
can end in a draw so king c5 came to f7
and now rook to g4 cutting off the white
king king to e6 and now king to d4 we
have king to f5 now comes h5
king to e6 we have knight to g3 taking
away the f5 square from the king king d7
king d5 king to c7 and now rook to b4
cutting off the uh the white king so
king d7 rook to b7 check king to c8 king
to c6 now and what can white play well
king to d8 now karpov goes after him we
have king the e8 king the e6 king to f8
and here king to a7 was played karpov
needs only a few more moves to deliver
checkmate but it was in this position on
move 83 that karpov's time ran out with
rey enigma having only one second on the
clock and that means that the game ends
in a draw
so uh really really impressive stuff
from ray enigma whoever he is uh he
really tried to flag carpool he he gave
it his best but it's incredible that
that karpov uh you know even at the this
age he he still plays three minutes
blitz games with uh
with such uh such precision okay he did
make that one uh little uh lapse in
judgment but uh you know uh
only one in a three minute blitz game
that's that's really that's really
perfectly fine it's it's hard to
also
imagine why enigma missed that rook the
rook to e3 move but you know it happens
i guess it was just too much uh lights
too much uh flashing too much explosions
too much everything there was even fire
on stage uh do check it out the link is
in the description below it's incredibly
intense if you if you thought this was
intense you will you know this will
completely blow your mind
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys uh enjoyed it like i said if you
know who he is don't share it with
everyone let it remain a mystery for for
as long as possible because the world
needs um well needs definitely such such
a character uh so yeah once again i hope
you guys uh enjoyed this and yeah i
forgot to mention uh as soon as this
position was reached a couple of time
ran out and he said tablas which is
as i understand it a draw in spanish so
yeah karpov first mentioned it i thought
it was really funny since enigma was
spanish
uh so yeah i hope you enjoyed it i would
like to thank uh frank combs uh kalatin
akun now francis ayer weaver sky music
and the model of reitzel for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
everything else that's happening in the
chess world and as usual checking up on
your wonderful suggestions uh thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day